Our brand new diatom t-shirt is now up for
pre-order over at microcosmos.store.
This shirt was designed by artist Josh Quick,
and is a part of our Artist Series, which
also features the recently restocked tardigrade
and hydra t-shirts.
And since it might be a little cold out there
for just a t-shirt, we also just restocked
the Homo sapiens sweatshirt.
Which I have and wear all the time.
And you can find that and the brand new diatom
t-shirt, along with microscopes, mugs, and
more at microcosmos.store.
We don’t often get a chance to reference
the rest of the cosmos, so we’re going to seize
the moment while we can.
When the astronomer Carl Sagan narrated the
series “Cosmos,” he famously said the following:
We are a way for the universe to know itself.
Some part of our being knows this is where
we came from.
We long to return.
And we can, because the cosmos
is also within us.
We’re made of star stuff.
Sagan was referring to the fact that our bodies
are built out of atoms that are billions of
years old, the pieces of stars that exploded
and scattered into space, eventually settling
into the matter that would form our earth
and then our bodies.
But looking at these ciliates, it's tempting
to take Sagan’s words more literally, to
imagine that the little twinkles of light
are actually stars…
…that we dived so deep into the microcosmos
that we have come full circle and stumbled
on the cosmos itself.
In place of a telescope though, we have a microscope,
aimed at a million colorful constellations
enclosed into their own galaxies and separated
by membranes.
But it takes more than just a microscope to
see the microcosmos lit up like this.
James, our master of microcosmos, has to use
a tool called a polarizer, which restricts
the vibration of light traveling towards our
samples.
When this polarized light hits certain types
of materials, the result is what we see here:
shiny crystals.
And as you might imagine, these intracellular
crystals have fascinated scientists for centuries.
But the actual nature of these crystals—what
they are made of and what purpose they serve—
that has been much murkier.
If you’ve been with us on our journey for
a while, you’ve probably heard us say the
phrase “we don’t know” a lot.
The microcosmos does not guarantee answers,
and we have often found ourselves looking
at some unusual behavior or beautiful form
that represents some fascinating,
unresolved mystery.
And this has happened almost every time we
have seen crystals in the microcosmos.
We see them, we wonder what they are for,
and then we move on to say “we don’t know.”
But the great thing about science is that
“we don’t know” is often a precursor
to people finding a way to learn more.
In the summer of 2022, a group of scientists
published a paper in the International Society
for Microbial Ecology describing their
investigation into the crystal structures
found within single-celled eukaryotes.
They used a technique called Raman microscopy,
which combines a standard microscope with
other tools—including a laser—to excite
the molecules within a sample in ways that
scientists can effectively read in plots and
graphs that reveal the identity of those molecules.
Every form of microscopy is a different way
of seeing the microcosmos.
And for the scientists working on this paper,
Raman microscopy allowed them to search through
more than 200 species of eukaryotes and identify
the crystals within them.
Now some of these crystals were previously known.
Molecules like calcite and oxalate and carotenoids.
And more than 80% of the organisms they studied
contained crystals made out of a type of compound
called purines.
Purines are present in many types of compounds
that are important to life:
DNA, RNA, ATP…even caffeine.
And in the case of these crystals, scientists
found purines appearing in different forms
like guanine and uric acid.
For algae, the guanine crystals might function
as nitrogen storage, helping the organisms
weather the fluctuations in nitrogen available
to them in the environment.
But there are also other types of crystals,
and other types of organisms that live in
different habitats with different needs, which
means there are likely many other functions
that we still do not know about.
The ubiquity of purine crystals suggests that
these types of crystals might be one of the
oldest forms of biocrystallization, present
in the last common ancestor to all eukaryotes.
So what does this mean for our organisms?
Well… we don’t know.
But identifying and characterizing these crystals
is just the first step on a longer journey,
one that will reveal more when we learn how
to see what is right in front of us.
And the more we learn about how these crystals
form and function in these organisms, the
more we will understand about the story of life
on earth, and even about how our own cells work.
Because these crystals—removed as they are
from the original star stuff they are made
of—they still tie the cosmos and microcosmos
together.
They are beacons that do more than simply
sparkle.
They illuminate.
Microbes, they show us a way to know ourselves,
a part of our being that knows this is where
we came from.
There is no need to return
because we are already there.
The microcosmos is within us, but more importantly,
we are in the microcosmos.
We are made of star stuff that has made the
same stuff: life.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Don’t forget to go to microcosmos.store
if you’d like to pre-order our brand new
diatom t-shirt, or pick up any of our other
microcosmos products.
The money from that store goes right back into
this channel, so when you pick up one of those
cool Hydra shirts, you can know that you are
are supporting what we do here.
And speaking of supporting this channel, all
the people whose names are on the screen right
now, they are our Patreon patrons.
They are the people who give a little bit
of money every month and in exchange they
get some cool stuff, but mostly I think the
thing that they get is knowing that they're
helping to make this little project continue
to exist.
Uh, because of course without them, it definitely
could not.
If you are interested in joining them, you
can check it out at Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there
is always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.